so then after the cop nuts they're like
oh
you're under arrest
[Music]
all right this story is a classic it's
one of those ones that you're like of
course
there is um a Hitman who created an
assassination for higher website
on the dark webs on the normal web
okay so an 18 year old woman in Miami
contacts a site about a hit job and
she's like hey I got a hit that I want
to take care of
um she sends photos and tells them the
job's got to be done by Thursday I
believe this is like Monday when it's
happening oh [__]
um the site then contacts the woman to
get details on it like okay I'll do your
hit let me get some more information
they agree on a fee of three thousand
dollars to assassinate the woman's
three-year-old son what oh my God what
did he do yeah he was tripping huh I
heard the uh after the terrible twos
there's the crazy threes that doesn't
rhyme though there's no alliteration
there what's speed there's no literation
there's no catch to it is it the crazy
craze
or the Tracy three the crazy thing I got
worse you never heard of those I never
heard of those terrible twos is the
theme three was cool Triple Threat three
I played three four it got better and
better better better better I kind of
made it up that's why it doesn't make
sense
tumultuous maybe it's it maybe it's the
it's the e3s
the y3s okay oh yeah
yeah maybe it's that yeah because I know
a lot of people that wanted to kill
their kid at two because they're like
this [__] [__]
it's a Louis CK bit right over some [__]
about twos he wants to kill his kids so
I think like
um when they're baby baby you're like oh
they're cute they can't really
communicate that's cool because they're
not really like mobile you know you set
them down here they're here then once
they get to like about one they start to
like be able to crawl some can walk they
can hop over the fence you have like
your little baby thing like you look
away for a second and then they're like
trying to stick their hands in like the
sockets
um and then when they're two I think
they start to like know that oh the
world isn't a program that I follow I
get to make my own choices but then also
they don't quite know how to communicate
just yet so everything is about me me me
me and if if I don't get what I want
I'll cry immediately but I'm also
extremely immobile so you have to be
very careful because they can get into
all kinds of crazy [__] and then also uh
when they're crying they're not they're
also not old enough to really articulate
what's happening so you can't really
reason or figure anything out so it's
just like a a Rubik's Cube that that is
constantly trying to commit suicide all
over the place that's pretty much what
it is sounds great but once they're
three they start being able to talk and
you can understand and the 40 gets
better and better and better and better
and you're like okay I understand now I
know why you did this when you're two
because you can articulate it so maybe
the baby just turned three probably
right so she's probably thinking she was
trying to assassinate yeah good reason
that's what it says amazing yeah I'm
good dude this crime unit is sick
terrible twos yeah so what happens is
they uh so they end up showing up at her
house to like because that's where the
kid is oh my gosh they go to the house
the mom opens the door for the Hitman
and what do you think what are you
thinking she gets arrested immediately
she gets arrested because the Hitman was
a cop because it hit man it's always a
cop classic classic assassination has
three asses and the website itself was
just a bait site that's some random
independent dude made so that he can
report to the cops who wants to have an
assessment there's no more Hitmen out
there I'll tell you that's fine it's all
cops was it assassination for hire.com
the four was a number four
assassin four higher they had a really
good copy on the website I thought um
she went on a telephone and wrote help
wanted and had those little phone
numbers killed that you rip off you guys
ready to kill I'm ready to pay you have
someone who's a pain in your ass that
needs to be removed but they know the
loophole a cop can't show you their dick
I'll see as soon as they hit matches up
show me your [__] dick
don't give them the secret Steve
intermediate this trial dude have you
seen all that like with prostitution
wait what but yeah so if you're a
prostitute like there's a there's like a
it was like a urban legend that cops
can't show you I didn't know that and so
yeah hella chicks were like show me your
dick and then they do and then the
copper recipe
they're like oh
oh [__] I forgot like situations where
there was like an let's say like a
Hitman was hired right it's never a
career Hitman that does that for a
living it's just a guy yeah who just
need it down as a luck yeah and he's had
other priors but he's just moved up to
like he's like three G's that sounds
like a good like they don't end up
linking him to five other hits like he's
just a [__] yeah because I feel like
if you're a real hit man your marketing
is probably like Word of Mouth probably
that's how it versus Facebook ads you're
not online right you're not online right
yeah play that you're not you don't you
don't really uh fall under the SEO
you can't play that game we still don't
know who killed Epstein for example
that's true like you know once bet she
was three thousand dollars yeah
yeah holy [__] this is a dumb question
uh because everybody's got a price how
much you charge usually off somebody
okay also that's fun how much would I
charge to off someone 69.5 do I you mean
I do the Dirty Work you're murdering
stuff you do all the work emotions you
don't know do I have to dump the body is
it a kid for hire no it doesn't matter
you this is what you're actually who
doesn't do kids dude honestly no I only
do kids I if it if it makes sense I
could get talked into killing someone if
it makes sense if it makes sense you're
adding morals to it I'm looking for a
price oh oh no no morals you're just
looking yeah but what if I show up and
it's a kid and I'm like ah then you go
like this I didn't know yeah
do you um you have to dispose of the
body what's the situation where it makes
sense to you do you think when it uh
makes sense let's say um there is
Justice was not served let's say
something happened to a family member
and they come in confine in me and then
I'm like oh okay and then the cops
didn't do anything okay well that means
Justice must be served every Father's
Day there's that post about the um
father whose kid got molested by the
karate teacher yeah and then he shows up
at the airport with a [__] gun and he
blows the guy away that's real fun yeah
he's on the phone booth yeah yeah phone
booth sunglasses did you see that
interview with the with the with the
pedo what he said is uh they would ask
him you know what type of targets you
would would you not go for and he goes
oh kids with strong dads they're like
kids that have got dads that look
aggressive
um or whatever stay away he's like
they'll kill you yeah like I told you
guys about what happened to me right
like [__] Kane Velasquez oh yeah
remember the UFC fighter he found out
that
um they're touching his kids this fool
went on a rampage drove his [__]
truck out was shooting with his AR like
dude this fool doesn't give up and he
was in jail for like ever and he's still
proud that he said I don't regret
anything that I did this is my these are
my kids you don't [__] with my kids yeah
did I tell you guys what happened to me
I think I did but it was a long time ago
um it was like 1995 or some [__] I was
like 10 years old and or nine barely and
then uh there was a guy in our
neighborhood and this was a national
news story like um I remember talking to
chip Reed from ABC because this [__] was
crazy no you did not tell us this okay
so there's a guy I think his name was
Tim I don't know if I can say his full
name allegedly his name is Tim Walsh but
it was a national news story and he was
in our neighborhood talking to all of us
I had a little group of friends right
it was me and a bunch of kids and he
used to take his moped and he was like
an older dude but like you know he's
like it like it seemed like he was like
an older kid almost because he would
like come in our neighborhood and he'd
like talk to us and then he would like
race us on his moped but we're on bikes
moped would have been a kid magnet for
me oh and it was as soon as the moped
come through I'm like bro [__] it I'm
right he was smart because he would race
us but let us win and then we're like
yeah we'd be showing him open a little
[__] you know I mean like but he was
like an overdue he's like over like I
think he was like 20 years old
and so then um my mom like all of a
sudden one day for my birthday we were
at Pizza Hut because that was like the
[__] happen in place right yeah it
was happening oh yeah I told I go up to
my mom and I'm like oh that's my friend
who like keeps on like come up to us in
the neighborhood the moped
and my mom's blood froze when she saw
him because she remember seeing him in
the paper
and she remembers this guy Tim Walsh who
actually we met in karate at jewelry
karate Taekwondo
um he would come he was a red belt and
he would come and he would like talk to
us and stuff this is years prior and
then my mom remembers in the paper
seeing that he got picked up for [__]
a kid in our neighborhood molesting him
sexually assaulting him
and then um so when I when when years
later I go that's my friend at the Pizza
Hut her blood freezes and she's like
holy [__] that's that [__] guy
and then
um she starts calling around and nobody
gives a [__] and the cops don't care and
then my mom's like you know what [__] it
so she goes to uh Kinko's and she like z
rocks is like all these flyers but did
you know this [__] child molesters in
our neighborhood talking to your [__]
kids and [__] oh [__] and she blasts it
she blasts it all over our neighborhood
everywhere she put it in like
everybody's doorstep and [__] it's
amazing and then the ACLU tried to sue
my my family after that which is crazy I
hate those guys forever are you [__]
kidding I didn't know ACLU [__]
protected pedals they do
um what's ACLU I thought American civil
liberties Union they go after people
that like talk [__] about they go out
look I agree with their mission
statement which is to like serve people
who deserve defense but this guy was a
con he was convicted and he was
violating his parole by talking to kids
but talking to kids and he wasn't
supposed to be even talking to me kids
and if I was in your friend group and
that fool pulled up in the moped I would
be going off into the sunset on his
moped exactly
was the fear was with my mom right
because you know we all knew not to do
that with strangers but he didn't seem
like a stranger he seemed like he was my
friend yeah so it was a different thing
he was establishing a relationship he
was grooming us basically right right
and then my mom was so [__] militant
that she did that and then because she
put the Flyers out it became a national
news story and then the cops got
involved and then he went back to court
and then he went back to jail but like
until then nobody was doing [__] so yeah
my mom's a [__] hero forever
strongest woman I've ever met wow what
was your dad doing
[__] off dude oh you give a [__] he
was too busy at work and [__] yeah
no he was working he's working what
would you guys do in that situation
I would pull up next to him in my moped
and be like wanna race
let's type I'll be like stop making it
all six yeah that's sexy that's hot
angel you're a kid no right now oh if I
found out that he was doing this in my
neighborhood and I'd be like want to
race and then as we're going side by
side I [__] kicked the [__] out of
that moped so he falls off of it and I
turn around and [__] run over his
whole body with my moped mopeds are
pretty small too
and he's like yeah
you can't go really that I mean it's
kind of fast you probably go like 40
miles per hour max dude imagine Joe
running against me [__] yeah right after
going won a race yeah wanna race
foreign
[Music]